finding your calling is easy I think
it's crazy that people don't know how to
find their calling I think it's among
the most important questions that you
need to figure out in life like how are
you living your life without knowing why
you're here what your calling is how
you're going to serve the message you
have they want impact that you want to
have it's crazy like you can't live a
happy fulfilled life until you know what
that is and it's not that difficult and
it just blows my mind because when you
figure it out the World's Gonna Change
can you imagine a world where everybody
has found their calling and is living it
I want to live in that world need
motivation Washington believe Nation hey
it's Nina Carmichael and the chances are
you are the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best by
husband Evan Carmichael and his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
rule number two believe you've got a
great idea
you know it can change the world you
know it could have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know what can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself and so
here's what's happened why well it's
because you've tried and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and you maybe saw a little bit
of tiny results but then you lose the
motivation and and you stop you've never
stayed with anything long enough to
actually let it see results and so you
built up this pattern inside yourself
that says I can't do it the idea is
great but I can't do it that's really at
the core if you really believe that you
could do it and you really believed in
the idea you'd be doing it and crushing
it so it's the biggest difference is why
lack of belief is the world's biggest
problem the only thing you're missing is
actual sustained momentum against your
ideas because if you believe that you
could do it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world but
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it rule number
mindset
happen to apply will help you eliminate
your self-doubt your fears your
insecurities and step forward
confidently into whatever situation you
get yourself into and it's this you
teach yourself that you can learn
anything you can learn anything you may
not have the answers right now you may
not know how to do the crazy thing that
you want to do you've got big goals big
Big Dreams big Ambitions you want to do
something big that's why you're watching
this channel right you're part of
believe Nation you want to do something
big with your life I love it you don't
know how to do it
you teach yourself I can learn anything
because what we often struggle with is
you want to do something you know you
can't do it yet and then you associate
with that I suck
I can't do something so I suck
and that attack on your self-worth on
your self-confidence on your self-esteem
prevents you from actually going off and
creating something amazing right I think
I think you're a genius I think you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
I believe that I don't just say it in
videos I believe that that's true
so whatever you're stuck on
instead of making yourself feel like you
suck that you're not good enough that
you're not capable of it understand that
it's just a skill set that's missing the
difference between where you're at right
now and where you want to be is the
skills that you acquire and in the
action that you're taking
you're willing to take action
problem is you probably don't have the
skills yet to be where you want to be
that's okay
you tell yourself I can learn anything
learning becomes your superpower rule
number four serve some people are built
to serve the world some people want to
have a giant Mission a giant Vision you
want to impact the lives of millions of
people that's me that may be you if
you're watching this that's most
entrepreneurs I think you have a giant
vision and you want to change the world
but some people are built to serve the
25 closest people to them if I look at
my wife Nina as an example she doesn't
have a giant Mission she doesn't have a
giant Vision but she still wants to
serve if you're not happy if you're not
happy in life it's because you're not
serving you're not serving deeply enough
to the people who you care most about or
you're not serving broadly enough to
have a big enough impact on the people
around you your community your country
your continent the world right
so entrepreneurs of default too I think
we want to serve the world they did
functional MRIs on the brain functional
MRIs and they studied the impact
of serving of helping other people and
it showed that when you serve other
people when you get the satisfaction if
you help somebody else out it touches
the same part of your brain as eating
food and having sex which are both also
pretty important things in life I think
you would agree
and so you're built to serve and and
they went deeper into the study and they
found that giving triggers it more than
receiving
so all of the stories that we know of
how gripping is great and Santa Claus
and you know it's better to give than to
receive and all this stuff right the
things that we've been told in our
stories that have been handed down to us
is backed up by science it's backed up
by science
so if you're not happy right now
if you're a little bit low right now the
easiest path out is service serve go
help people if you woke up every day and
felt like the work that you did matter
to somebody either to again the closest
people to you like my wife who's still
in touch with their friends from
kindergarten in China
to someone like me who wants to have a
giant impact and reach a billion people
around the world if you're not happy all
you have to do is start to serve also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five take action The
Law of Attraction definitely works most
people just get it wrong most people
only focus on the thinking part and not
the most important part which is the
action right a lot of attractions the
last five letters that matter
a-c-t-i-o-a-c-t-i-o-n six the last six
letters of the matter action action
action thinking about it alone is not
enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something to your life you want to
manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happier relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it and
believing in it is already a big step
ahead of where most people are most
people live in a Negative Zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're gonna focus on your new goal your
new habit the new thing that you want
into your life amazing you believe that
it's possible amazing you're putting up
a vision board with it on your wall
amazing you're researching and watching
videos like this every day amazing
that's great that's the first starting
point but nothing happens until you take
action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but you're still just going to be
this super smart super ambitious person
sitting at home not achieving your goals
you have to do something I look at my
YouTube channel as an example uh my main
Channel I want to get the 10 million
subscribers that's my next goal right we
hit one we hit two I gotta hit ten uh at
the rate that we're growing it's not
fast enough like it's gonna take me way
too many years to make it happen so I
need to apply more pressure against it
so part of what I look at every day now
in my morning routine is I want to hit
my goal I want to get 10 million
subscribers on my YouTube channel right
I want to be you know one of the first
thought leaders experts business person
to have 10 million subscribers on a
YouTube channel it's my next goal great
writing that down every day doesn't make
sure that it's gonna happen what am I
doing right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am I actually doing well I'll tell
you what I'm doing now one of the
biggest things I'm working on now big
new Initiative for my team is I've got 6
000 public videos on my my main Channel
and I told my team this week I want to
go back and update all of the thumbnails
and all of the titles across all my
videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6000
videos imagine doing split tests on all
of those videos I asked for 10 a day and
so to keep people on my team are working
together to come up with what the title
is going to be and then the other one's
doing the graphic design to create the
thumbnails maybe it works the first time
but maybe it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day you know in a year if we
did it for 10 videos every day we're
just over half of those videos assuming
that they all work out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome I might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 tests a day 40 split tests a day
100 split deaths a day I don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're going in circles
without any clear Direction most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching Dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important I do it every
day it's why I create all these channels
I think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video I have a
question of the day or I have a
three-point Landing question because I
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch after every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
that that's not enough you have to do
something about it I'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less if you're
taking action on the ideas that come to
you because most people are just
professional consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
Netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action rule number six
listen to your heart so your head only
understands a world that exists your
head is logical it's practical and so
whatever's been done can be done again
right it's logical and so if you've got
a job at some company you know you can
make X thousands of dollars a year
that's that's safe that's logical that's
practical you know what can be done it
exists other people have done it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path and it's not
necessarily wrong it's not malicious
they're not trying to hurt you
it's just fear-based and so it's small
you never create amazing things when
you're living in a fear-based state and
that's what you're doing when you make
big decisions with your head because
your head only understands a practical
world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's never existed before your heart
is where all the artists lives all the
all the game changers live all the
people who end up making massive change
in the world that's where they live
they're creating something new they say
I see something that other people don't
see and I can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where I know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where I know
you're at the problem is living inside
your head instead of living inside your
heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days where you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days I'm gonna
switch my hand my hand's getting tired
I'm holding the video you'll have some
days where you'll actually feel that way
like maybe I can I can be the person I
am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up and you get inspired you
had a great dream something happens you
have this moment where you just feel
bold powerful and software and say
today's my day I'm gonna go off and do
it and crush it right we've all had
those moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself I can't do this I
didn't go to school for this I don't
have the money for this I don't have the
talent for this I'm not good enough for
this I'm I'm not brave enough for
creatures enough for this right that's
all you're ahead talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is you're heading your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on YouTube that you want to fill in a
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
as your head is always going to say whoa
whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're gonna listen
to your head and the people around you
will tell you listen to your head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't your heart has to decide
the big decisions in your life treat you
go move to that other country or other
City should you go marry that person or
not should you go take that job or not
she should go start that business or not
big decisions with your heart and then
you use your head to help you figure out
the how rule number seven seven stop
judging yourself making decisions for
your life based off of what other people
expect you to do is the fastest way to
hate your life most people actually hate
their lives most people are not doing
the thing that they could be great at
and they're judging you for you going
off and chasing down your dream
listening to them is the fastest way to
crush your dreams and never achieve the
Michael Jordan love of greatness that
you have inside you
you're a weird duck this is one thing
that I've learned from all of my travels
from all the entrepreneurs I visited
around the world I'm a weird duck and so
are you you're a weird duck you like
weird things you're not normal you don't
want to be normal you don't want to be
normal you do not want to be normal
and yet you judge yourself based off of
what other people expect a normal person
to do and it's time to stop and and I'm
leaning into it more and more and more
and more and more and I hope I can give
you permission to lean into it more and
more and more as well
I'm here with beautiful Puerto Rico
we're taking a walk down the beach
earlier today with my wife Dina and
we're supposed to film but the the sound
on the beach is crazy hopefully you can
still hear it here it's still got some
wind but on the water it's a crazy windy
day so we came back off the film and as
I was walking did a quick Instagram
video
of just my feet in the sand and somebody
DM me as a response to say man
if I was there I'd have a really hard
time focusing on work
and I responded I can't wait to get back
to my room to go film
like this is beautiful I love it it's
amazing right like what a scenery I'm
blessed to be here grateful that I can
have the kind of business that allows me
to travel and see these awesome places
but I love the work
I love working I love making videos for
you guys I can't wait to plan you know
the next week the next month the next
quarter for what I'm going to be doing
in my business I love it
after I'm done filming you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna go down on
the beach we're gonna go down there and
go do those see those
chairs right there we're gonna go down
there
Nina's gonna work on her tan
probably passed out that's the goal she
wants to try to sleep I'm gonna be
working I'm gonna be working I'm going
to be I'm gonna be looking at my YouTube
stats I'm gonna be planning my
membership course I'm gonna be looking
at my YouTube growth boot camp I'm going
to be working on the book launch I'm
going to be working and I love it
I love it
and that's weird that's not what that's
not what most of these people want to do
right that's not what that's not what
these guys want to do that's not what
but most people come to a place like
this to escape a life that they hate
they come to a place like this for a
couple days or for a week to escape a
life that they hate they can run away
that's when I lie on the beach and
forget my life
forget that that world exists and just
Escape
I think this is a huge mistake there's
nothing wrong if you love the beach you
love the ocean you love the weather it's
beautiful weather coming from Toronto
Canada we're buried under snow right now
so this is beautiful weather there's
nothing wrong with that
but what's better is fixing your life
if you're looking forward to your next
vacation that's amazing because you're
looking forward to it but not because
you're trying to run away from something
and that's what most people are doing
that's what most people are doing they
run away from a life that they hate
it's not the path and these are the
people whose opinions you're worried
about
the people who wake up every day go to a
job that they hate so that once a year
they can come on a vacation like this
are telling you that you suck that
you're crazy that you shouldn't be doing
this crazy thing
they gave up on their dreams years ago
don't let that infect you and it's not
that they suck and that you need to put
them down
but you can't let that toxicity seep
into yourself rule number eight be bold
every day you have a choice every day
you have to decide who's gonna show up
today
is it gonna be the you who settles who
stays comfortable who does what
everybody wants you to do who just is
afraid of scared is unwilling to do the
things that you need to do to go off and
accomplish your dreams or
is it gonna be the Bold version the
courageous version the one who believes
that you can create something that
nobody else around you believes is
possible to create that's a daily battle
even for me it's a daily battle
we wake up and have to fight ourselves
every day because no matter how great a
day you had yesterday no matter how bold
you're feeling today tomorrow is a new
battle
is a new day
and with time yes you can raise your
Baseline so that what a morning feels
like is not as bad as it used to be but
the decision to be bold courageous
Unstoppable is a daily battle for
everybody
the difference what makes a difference a
difference between the people who wake
up and then go off and doing amazing
things and the people who just stay
small and stay stuck knowing that
they're capable of more the difference
is that successful people demand
Excellence from themselves every day
and it starts with having a morning
routine that sets them up for success
what is your morning routine
now some of you may have a morning
routine you may be thinking oh not
another morning routine video
listen if you're not feeling bold and
confident every day your morning routine
is not serving you and you might have
the best morning routine of anybody that
you know you might be the only person
who's working out every morning or who's
watching a video every morning or
spending any kind of time on themselves
every morning because most people wake
up like an accident most people wake up
check their phones start responding to
other people's emergencies and never
spend any time building the life or the
person that they want to build right
that's most people that's fine that's
not you probably if you're watching this
video You're subscribed to this channel
that's probably not you
but it doesn't mean that your morning
routine can't serve you better
test for a great morning routine is do
you feel bold courageous and Unstoppable
every day after finishing it
a lot of people just go through the
motions a lot of people watch your video
like this while they're making breakfast
or cleaning the sink or doing something
else you're not focused you're not
paying attention
you need to because if you're not
focused and paying attention to what
you're doing in your morning routine
you're not getting the feeling that you
need to feel at the end of your morning
routine I don't care if your morning
routine takes you five minutes or two
hours do you feel bold powerful
Unstoppable courageous at the end of it
if not you need to fix it
now what makes a routine get somebody to
feeling bold powerful courageous
Unstoppable is different for different
people right the thing is
I'm gonna switch my hand here getting
tired
the thing is everybody has something
that makes you feel that feeling you
felt it before
and what it is for me is always going to
come down to service and feeling like
the work that I do matters isn't
important so the thing I do in my
morning routine is I always share a
daily message and so go to my Instagram
and I'll share a daily message and I
remind myself that what I do matters it
serves people it's having an impact
right if if you woke up and felt like
the work you did every day
was going to have an impact you'd be a
lot more bold courageous and willing to
take bigger chances and so that's what I
try to do every single morning
but what works for me may not work for
you that's okay
the good news is you felt bold you have
felt courageous you have felt
Unstoppable at some point in your life
the problem is it's just not consistent
so what is the thing that you did that
you experienced to help you feel that
level of boldness where you felt like
you were capable of doing things greater
than what you're doing right now what
what happened what experienced were you
were you watching the video were you
listen to a podcast where you're doing
an active service were you sharing a
message were you talking to your mom
like what were you doing were you
meditating naked with your cat outside I
don't care what it is right what did you
do that made you feel bold powerful
Unstoppable and confident and then how
can you inject that into your daily life
every day so you start every day with
that thing
as a reminder for you to go off and live
a courageous bold powerful life because
what you're doing now is Tiny compared
to what you're capable of and chances
are there's nobody in your life who's
pushing you like you need to be pushed
you're probably the person pushing other
people to do great things and other
people in your life they may not be
supportive they may be supportive but
even the ones who are supportive
even the ones who are supportive are not
telling you this thing you're doing is
great and you know what you could be
doing way better man
like this is small compared to what
you're capable of
the people who are supportive
they love you they're cheering you on
but they think you're great
their version of greatness is Tiny
compared to yours and you know it
it's awesome to be seen as great in
their eyes but you know you're capable
of way way way way way more and that
doesn't happen if you're waking up every
day and just feeling okay if you're
waking up every day in doubt in fear and
insecurity and that's how you show up to
life
you cannot allow yourself to show up
every day in life feeling insecure
cowardly small scared afraid little
it's a choice
and it's easy to see there by default
because our head keeps us afraid rule
number nine appreciate little wins the
only
you're a genius you have great ideas
that idea you have in your head is
amazing can work can make a lot of money
can impact the world can serve the
people around you you're a genius you've
got Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you've got Grant Cardone level
Talent that's something you you even
though everybody telling you you can't
nobody's done in your family before
nobody's done it for your community
before you can do it you've got it the
only thing the only only only only thing
that you're missing
is momentum
you're not doing enough you're not
getting enough results you're not
getting the little wins the little ones
like the bigger ones eat the more wins
and the bigger ones like the bigger wins
momentum
I have a YouTube course
that I put out in once a month I'm in a
Facebook group and we do a live chat
with the people who bought the course to
help them continue to grow and blow up
their Channel and two days ago I posted
in the group to say pay for our next
call that's coming up what do you want
to learn how can I help we've got this
once a month time together you and me
solo time like what can I help you with
what topics do you want to learn more
about and you know what the number one
response was
the number one response that people
voted up was how to stay motivated when
you're not getting results
how to stay motivated when you're not
getting results it wasn't a tactical
thing it wasn't how do I fix my
thumbnails how do I fix my intros where
do I type up my video do you like my
color scheme what topic should I create
how often do I post how long should a
video be none of that stuff is how do I
stay motivated when I'm not getting
instant early results
and so that's what we're going to talk
about next week on the call when we get
on
and I think back to when I first started
and there's lessons here for you not
just if you're interested in YouTube but
whatever you're doing
when I first started
I started speaking before I started
doing YouTube and I remember I would go
into a speaking gig and my first one
only three people showed up and I would
feel such a high after the speaking gig
like man what I what this matters this
is amazing I just helped some people and
then wake up the next day
and feel no energy no momentum it's like
man
no I don't believe in myself anymore
who am I to go and do this all of a
sudden the question the doubt the
insecurities just take over again like
where was he having from yesterday
and so what I did was
after every time I did a presentation I
asked for feedback and people would
email me their feedback and and the best
feedback I put into a PowerPoint file
I put into a PowerPoint panel I'd watch
this presentation every morning that I
made super simple and put it to a music
soundtrack that I liked and it would
just be instant over and over and over
again all the feedback that I got to
remind myself that the work that I did
matters because yesterday it felt
amazing because I was out there speaking
and helping people but today it doesn't
feel real anymore
it's crazy how that can happen overnight
and so I watched the PowerPoint file
every morning to remind myself that the
work that I do matters that this is
happening that even if I've only touched
three people I touched three people it
helped them it was meaningful to them
and I have to keep going right it's the
small wins the momentum the only thing I
was missing was momentum the same thing
for you when I first started on YouTube
the first video that I put up
was on Walt Disney and my mom commented
on it and my sister commented on it and
then one other random person I don't
know commented on it in the first year
so think about it the first year of me
having my YouTube channel up my first
video
three comments on that video and one was
my mom and one was my sister so only
really one comment from a stranger
someone I didn't know on my first video
after one year of it being live isn't
that crazy
and so what I would do is I'd look at my
comments every day and even though
they'd be the same comments because I
wasn't getting very many
even see my mom's comment or my sister's
comment or that one random dude's
comment knowing that hey
and touch that one random dude I have to
keep going
I gotta keep moving it
now I'm I'm spoiled you know every day I
still look at comments as part of my
daily routine as a reminder to myself
that this like this stuff the Beach
views that kind of stuff that doesn't
motivate me that doesn't motivate me
it's fun being here I'm blessed and
grateful to have the kind of business
that can take me here and and travel
around the world new speaking gigs and
all that kind of stuff it's amazing but
the thing that gets me up that motivates
me that fires me up is knowing that
people are consuming my content and it
makes a difference rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
could have changed your circle we don't
change the people we hang out with
because we're afraid we're afraid that
we're not going to find new people we're
afraid that we don't know where to find
new people we're afraid that we're going
to get rejected and judged by these new
people we're afraid that if we lose the
people who are hanging around us right
now that will have nobody that we're
starting over from scratch and we don't
know what to do and it's better to be
with people who are just okay than to be
lonely and be by ourselves that that's
the problem you're just afraid
but here's the thing if you don't change
it if you don't change your circle
you're never going to grow
chances are right now you are the most
ambitious person that you know you're
the most ambitious person the happiest
person most positive person the most
optimistic the most ambitious the most
loving caring Big Dreams person in your
circle
chances are that's you and that's
amazing that's an amazing gift that you
can give to the people you can pull
other people up and you can support them
and cheer them on but who's doing that
for you who's pulling you up who do you
hang out with who makes you feel like
you need to get better who's pulling you
into a different world who says hey you
can be more positive you can play a
bigger game you need to believe in
yourself more who does that for you
chances are nobody
the problem that's also maybe why you're
watching these videos it's why I make
these videos on my channels because I
want to try to be that person for people
I want people to believe in themselves
more and content is definitely a way to
do it this is the starting point but you
have to decide that you're ready to play
a bigger game and that comes with making
changes in your life and that comes with
taking some people out of your life
now doesn't mean you cut them out
completely maybe it does maybe it
doesn't you know if your mom is always
the one being negative and telling you
that you suck or question you on things
maybe you don't want to cut her out of
your life but just because you are
friends with somebody in high school or
kindergarten doesn't mean that you
should still be friends now a lot of us
are in these relationships out of
convenience and because it's how it's
it's been you've always been friends
with this person so you must stay
friends with this person it doesn't mean
you have to become mortal enemies but
you're gonna outgrow people think about
how much you've grown in the past 10
years 20 years think about me I'm
turning 40 in May so you know 20 years
since University the people who I was
with University in in 30 years since
school
man how much have I grown in the past 30
years how much have you grown in the
past 20 years
how much have the people around you
grown probably not that much
and so if you keep growing growing
growing growing growing growing and
they're just kind of staying where they
are
slowly loose things to be able to talk
about and connect over
and so you might pull them up a little
bit
but you can only pull them up to the
extent that you've grown
and they're likely pulling you down in a
lot of areas
and so you have to do an audit my
recommendation is you do an audit you do
an audit in your life you do an audit of
the people around you think about who
you hang out with the most
start with the people like who are you
hanging out with the most your friends
your family
people in your Social Circle people at
work who you hanging out with the most
and who actually gives you energy do it
on it who gives you energy
and if they're giving you energy you
want to spend more time with them you
want to try to spend more time with them
and if they're sucking your energy dry
every time if you're leaving
conversation with people feeling
depleted
negative pessimistic man you really need
to spend less time with that person or
just shut them out of your life
completely
because you living around negative
pessimistic people is not going to let
you go off and build something amazing
your energy changes how you show up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed sad for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not
something new that I'm telling you you
know this
the challenge is we are not in a high
energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals so follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to the Press our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people with a worse version
of your idea
but just more energy go off and do it
have you ever seen it happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action and just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so
If energy is so important then how do we
how do we manage our energy how do we
keep it high and it doesn't mean that
you always have to be on top of the
world and you don't have to delude
yourself and say I'm amazing this is
going to be the greatest day of all time
like you don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you do need to do is be in the
right energy to serve your mission and
whatever you're doing today so let me
use me as an example on today
is a great example because I did not
sleep well last night had had two and a
half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and
just could not
could not get to sleep so I slept from
like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did not sleep
until 6 30 in the morning
and that is thankfully a rare occurrence
you know most nights I get eight hours
sleep seven and a half to eight and a
half hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something that would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway
so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen
so if you start to train yourself and
you create a calendar and say okay
today is a blank I'm filming this on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday Tuesday's my
video day no matter what I'm filming
videos I gotta film videos it's got to
happen it may not be my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside
you know get outside get fresh air get
some sun on my face if you you know you
want to change your energy you want to
shift where you're at and how you're
thinking because it's part physical
energy but also just mental energy how
do you feel about what you're doing and
what's going to happen today and getting
out of your home changing your physical
environment getting some sun on your
face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier
a little bit more in the right energy
space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song and you feel chill you put on a
Chill song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember on the weekend
and you gotta guard against this it's
crazy so on the weekend I went to go
meets an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back like oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
Ripple effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this way thinking this way I don't like
it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I applied a lot of the same things I got
it I went outside went outside reset get
some fresh air it always helps me put on
some music songs that I actually like
not some fake song that somebody else
likes and says dance to this it'll make
you feel good as long as I actually like
there are some songs that if it came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go [ __ ] and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you you would Bob your head or you would
tap your feet or bounce your knee
there's some songs that just make you do
that right so put on one of those songs
it would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just gardening against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
uh which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiling and happy had dreams for
the future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but
having positive energy is natural having
sunshine and leading to happiness is
natural putting on music and and dancing
and moving is natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the hours like
it's okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day
you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
I thought you're on top of the world and
the fake high every day but a better
energy state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much does your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy think big
small think big have a big goal Big
Dreams big desires big mission big big
Vision you're going to change the world
think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us and
nobody's seen us I just finished this
seven day challenge uh and built to
serve helping people become thought
leaders and people are afraid of people
watching their content and what their
what those people are going to say and
they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look and your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not gonna be very
good probably
but that's okay doesn't mean you suck as
a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and you don't meet those
expectations and this Gap this is the
gap that prevents you from taking
further action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you recorded a video
watched it back were completely
embarrassed by yourself and then never
posted it and never launched your
channel there's been people who I've
done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent interview
but the insecurity is interferious and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect a suck at the beginning
just expect a suck expected to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
you can learn it of course you can learn
it
pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having a skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the trading education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movement makers
uh his name is Michael he's an amazing
human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of asking people to be on the
show and him being the interview were he
was fine being an interviewee when
people were asking him questions but he
didn't want to be the interviewer and
was afraid to ask people questions and
so we had a discussion and we came up
with a concept where it was
um his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with a concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation he had a
guest come on and he was doing the
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expected to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better and a little bit better and when
you look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days
100 days you'll come back and say holy
cow I'm really getting better why
because you developed a skill you were
you were still the same awesome human
now you're developing the skill set to
actually get better at the thing that
you want to do makes all the difference
the only thing you're missing is
momentum so just repeat yourself repeat
to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
all you're missing is momentum you're
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that helped me that that that
gives me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the bar is solo that there is
no bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it it's a good idea
trust that that is the right idea for
you that you should do it that you
should take action on it and that is
going to serve if you're in a positive
mindset right if you're if you're in a
negative mindset then then it's good to
sleep on your ideas right if you're in a
jealous mindset or hateful mindset or
rageful mindset then the ideas that come
to you are probably not the right ideas
for you but if you're in a powering
empowering inspiring positive optimistic
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are the right ones for you and just
trust that those are the right ideas
and do something on it and shortcut your
brain because as soon as your brain
takes over it's gonna be like oh okay
but you don't know how to do this and
that and and here's another problem and
more restrictions and you you know okay
so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep coming in high and then you know
next week I'll do something and then
next week comes and you haven't done it
yet right so when an idea comes to you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today don't make it some
big giant thing that now you need a
million dollars in venture capital and a
huge team to accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
get rid of your 10-year goals and create
a mission instead
I think a lot of people are so worried
about where they're going to be in a
year and five years and 10 years we do
these goals planning actually you ever
gone through that you ever gone through
a goal planning exercise goal said and
exercise at events you read a book says
we're going to be in a year in five
years or ten years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercises the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
to plan a life for who you are right now
it's like there's no way there's no way
not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world involves the new technology comes
out and New Opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head it might flip a lot
of what you've been told or taught or
thought on its head and listen if having
that 10-year goal works for you and is
actually motivating cool keep keep with
it keep going if it's helping you use it
but if you feel like there's something
more or you feel like 10 year goal is
not enough you don't feel motivated when
you look at your 10-year goal from two
years ago it doesn't appeal to you
anymore it's probably why you know
you're you're growing too quickly the
problem is not your goals the problems
that you grew too much the 10-year goal
is great for who you were three years
ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turning to the next generation
of you
and So my answer is admission what's the
mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so it was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here
there's no way just with the with the
impact I've had with the people I've met
with the even just the confidence to sit
here guys I would have been so terrified
to sit in a park making a video
terrified of who's watching me who's
judging me who's coming around the
corner who's behind there maybe you know
looking at me and judging me you know it
would have been impossible so the person
I was 10 years ago would have never even
thought of this as a possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you can with a mission it's a
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the mark and the
technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the machine well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that
this video in some way is a video that
moves a needle just a little bit for
somebody watching maybe it's you maybe
this is the video that you decide I'm
gonna I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
find my mission I'm gonna stop creating
10-year goals and stop over planning
over preparing and overthinking and over
strategizing and over doubting myself
and just go do something like maybe
today this is the video or maybe I'm
making another video today that
accomplishes that like that's that's my
goal that's why I do what I do that's
what gives me the energy to wake up when
every bone in my body is saying you know
sleep don't do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you can think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go you're
by no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck in your story your message your
content you reaching out you could make
the difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you want to outgrow
is the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it focus on
one idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12 mostly
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people got a big
message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know it
doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's a social media
success whatever it is what you have to
figure out is how do I start to as soon
as possible get a sustainable business
for myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money that then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone help me with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have a family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I looked at a lot of thought leaders a
lot of people have a message a lot of
people want to be speakers and authors
and coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching
if we had those are four opportunities
in front of you right let's say so what
did I say being a speaker getting paid
to speak getting paid to do brand deals
getting paid to be an author and selling
books
um even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service than a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
written your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there a lot of people wake up like that
though most people wake up and hope
something happens to them hopes they win
the lottery hopes to get the promotion
hope some big customer calls them right
we're just living a land of I hope
something big happens to me but I don't
believe